elfter april karsamstag am grenzübergang
suben verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner besucht hier soldaten des
österreichischen bundesheeres während
ihres sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz es zurzeit sind
insgesamt 232 soldaten in oberösterreich
an mehreren grenzübergängen im einsatz
sie stellen sich aus teilen des
militärkommandos oberösterreich zügen
des stabs bataillons 3 der dritte
jägerbrigade und soldaten der harris
unteroffiziers akademie zusammen
meine kompanie unterstützt hier die
gesundheitsbehörde
das ist der große unterschied zum
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz dass wir von der
gesundheitsbehörde das bedeutet von der
bezirkshauptmannschaft über das land
oberösterreich angefordert werden um
eben gesundheits polizeilich einreise an
den grenzen zu überprüfen
das bedeutet wenn jetzt die
verschiedenen personengruppen
in das land einreisen so wird
hauptsächlich von uns das fieber
gemessen und wenn es die umstände
erfordern die diversen formulare
ausgefüllt einerseits entweder werden
abweisungen durchgeführt oder es gibt
eine 14-tägige quarantäne oder die
verschiedenen personen müssen sich
entsprechend an der bei den behörden
behördlichen stellen melden
hier in suchen vorsieht auch der
militärmusik zug über die osterfeiertage
seinen dienst weshalb es nicht
verwundert dass es zu einer spontanen
musikalischen einlage kommt aber auch
die verteidigungsministerin ist nicht
mit leeren händen gekommen
als symbolisches zeichen des dankes und
der anerkennung gibt es für die soldaten
eine osterhase mit lokalen spezialitäten
was man hier sieht und spürt und in den
gesprächen die wir geführt haben dann
auch hört ist dass die zusammenarbeit
zwischen der exekutive unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten wirklich
exzellent funktioniert das wurde ja auch
bestätigt sehr vieles wäre unser dass
unser österreichisches bundesheer nicht
möglich es gilt hier ein ganz großes
dankeschön den soldatinnen und soldaten
zu sagen die hier auch über die
osterfeiertage im einsatz sind und
erlauben sie mir auch noch anders zu
sagen sind ja einige im einsatz die
front der militärmusik kommen
es hat mich sehr gefreut dass ja auch
ein ständchen gebracht worden ist
die bevölkerung kann sich sicher fühlen
auch in gesundheitlicher
ansicht dass die danke zu sagen wir
können stolz sein auf unser
österreichisches bundesheer in der
herausforderndsten zeit die wir seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg erleben mussten